richtig clever ist aber die firma
vattenfall der schwedische konzern klagt
nämlich noch zusätzlich vor einem
schiedsgericht in washington gegen
deutschland das verfahren läuft wir
schalten live vor die deutsche
vattenfall zentrale in berlin zu dennis
knossalla dennis die kriegen den hals
aber auch nicht voll oder was haben sie
denn erwartet das sind schweden eine
nation von skrupellosen kaufleuten was
die schon an unglück über die welt
gebracht haben aber aber das musical
aber der film und natürlich die
hutablage lustig dass hin böse menschen
sicher denn es keiner markt schweden
aber kann vattenfall nicht trotzdem
akzeptieren dass wir diese gefährliche
technologie nach fukushima schlicht
nicht mehr wollen also gefährlich ist ja
mal relativ beispiel tschernobyl gut
campingurlaub würde ich da jetzt auch
ungern buchen aber dramatisieren darf
man es natürlich nicht dieser kollege
zeigt den richtigen spirit
wir stehen jetzt im grunde genommen von
dem reaktorblock zu 150 meter entfernt
der damals explodiert ist und danach
durch den brand natürlich auch noch
weiter beschädigt wurde
ja hier ist noch strahlung also ich habe
hier mal dieses messgerät dass wir bei
uns haben und das schlägt auch natürlich
deutlich an
ich mach das nochmal während der
schalter aus und stört das so
immer noch das beste mittel gegen
strahlung einfach das messgerät
ausmachen
aber jetzt mal im ernst tschernobyl
macht's doch vor da wird gerade ein
riesiger stahl sagt über die ruine
drüber geschoben die beste lösung für
alles einfach zu decken
ich sag mal wenn wir rechtzeitig eine
schutzhülle über alexander dobrindt
andere geschichte ja wenn es so einfach
wäre schutzhülle in frankreich mussten
sie gerade wegen materialfehlern 18
reaktoren runterfahren darunter auch
block 2 in fessenheim oja fessenheim
das ist so nah an der grenze da können
sie von deutschland aus einen stein
drauf werfen
das dürfen sie auf keinen fall machen
aber von der entfernung her
deshalb sage ich ja bevor ich mühsam die
ganzen französischen reaktoren einzeln
repariere einfach sagen vater drüber und
feierabend problem gelöst seien
die sarkophag lösung für alles
sehr schön aber doch noch mal zurück zum
vattenfall welche chancen haben die
schweden gegen deutschland in washington
die juristen sagen ziemlich gute
schiedsgericht entscheiden gerne pro
konzern bis zu fünf milliarden könnte
das den steuerzahler am ende kosten
es sei denn ist das geil dass schweden
das ist die rache für kliniker brot und
köttbullar was ist eigentlich dringend
etwas zeit bei mir in der nachbarschaft
kehrte ausgemacht hat sind alle
verschwunden
denken sie mal darüber nach später gern
dennis knossalla meine damen und herren
[Applaus]